Texas seems a long way away on this
rainy Wednesday morning in Poznan but in
his head victory ARCA is already in the
Lone Star State ironically his what
colleagues there are all in bed four
years ago ya're completed his degree in
economics and information technology he
got a job as a programmer with a Poznan
company but that didn't work problem was
they stopped paying me at some point
even though I was doing my job and
everything so
I remember my friends once and they
recommended either a website yurka
decided to go freelance and look for
work with the help of a website called
oDesk a young entrepreneur from the US
got in touch
he was having more work than he could
handle
and I need some people that could do a
good development work and in Poland at
first Yaga did the work himself but what
was a two-man operation has grown into a
company with 25 employees in both the US
and Poland their customers are companies
who want online shops Poznan is mainly
about creating the software writing code
like we all we have here as programmers
and testers and the United States office
is mostly about getting us clients and
sales the programmers in Poznan worked
together with their American colleagues
using cloud technology this is part of a
major global trend companies save their
data on central servers that are
connected via the Internet
cloud computering is one reason Poznan
is booming critics may object that
clouds aren't a safe place to store data
but there's no turning back the clock
where this technology is concerned
another person who works in the clouds
of Posner and his 30 year old Viktor
Schmidt a trained engineer five years
ago he started a company called net
furrow he creates apps designs websites
and maintains online portals for
companies abroad so the clients come to
us with with a project with an idea with
the specification and what we do is make
sure that from the technical point of
view they're there covers the all the
work is done properly they need to think
of the business companies don't need to
buy expensive software or employ
full-time experts of their own most of
our clients are around Europe so
supposed to be UK Ireland Germany and if
a few in the US you can even you
entreated somebody who's basically
sitting in a different room but this
room is not you know in the same office
it's just somewhere somewhere else net
guru now has just under 50 employees and
the company plans to expand in the
coming years
Poland formerly an agricultural nation
has become an IT hotspot bar tech
bronowsky and toffee Katsura also
service customers from the u.s. to dubai
punished computer experts work for lower
wages than their peers elsewhere and
their training is highly rated
for example university of technology
which majority of our developers are
graduated from is it's also very known
for its for releasing quality graduates
with demand so high programmers are in
short supply in Poznan sobre Nevsky and
kageura have opened an affiliate in kaki
of Ukraine the just limited number of
people you can hire and that's it
so we have to find other people
somewhere else now this is this is this
is a different idea for sourcing the
people usually consider it because when
they think I'm exhausted they think to
publish entrepreneurs are trying to
establish a reputation for high quality
work Viktor Schmidt meets up with
colleagues and fellow programmers most
come from the region the idea is to
maintain a network most of these young
people have already spent time abroad
I can only see this the same thing we
are thanks to new technologies these
people no longer have to leave home to
find work they now work on cloud 9